Did the official Star Wars website accidentally
spoil a plot point in The Rise of Skywalker?
It sure looks that way.
In the newest available footage from the film,
first released at Disney's D23 Expo on August
24 and then released online August 26, Rey
is briefly seen cloaked in a black robe with
a stern look on her face as she brandishes
a double-bladed red lightsaber.
Her pale skin, rigid movements, attire, and
new weapon of choice that calls to mind the
saber that Darth Maul wielded all fueled what
has become a popular fan theory about "Dark
Rey": she's a vision of a possible future.
Fans thought they would only be able to confirm
or cancel out that theory by watching The
Rise of Skywalker in theaters, but on August
27, eagle-eyed Star Wars enthusiasts spotted
a slip-up published on the franchise's website.
Just after Lucasfilm took the stage at D23
to talk all things Rise of Skywalker, StarWars.com
ran a news piece breaking down what was shown
at the presentation.
The final paragraph focused on the new Rise
of Skywalker footage, highlighting Dark Rey.
One Redditor grabbed a screenshot of the first
version of the post on StarWars.com, which
read in part,
"The wise words were also part of the first
trailer for the film, but the new footage,
including a moment where Rey appears to toss
a fully-ignited lightsaber, and of course
the vision of Rey with a reticulated red blade,
was nothing short of thrilling."
The article has since been updated to replace
the word "vision" with "sight."
On one hand, it could be taken as an accidental
leak.
Maybe the StarWars.com staff had some inside
information, and that top-secret intel slipped
through the cracks and made its way into the
published version of the article.
If that's the case, it likely wasn't intentional,
but the slip-up is pretty big.
"This was a mistake!"
On the other hand, this could just be an unfortunate
phrasing.
Star Wars secrets are usually kept more secure
than John Wick's stash of weapons, so it seems
pretty unlikely that the StarWars.com editorial
team would be privy to plot details that the
general public isn't.
As many Redditors have noted, the writer was
possibly thinking more of the definition of
"sight" when writing the post, but used the
synonym "vision."
It's plausible that the writer was merely
trying to speak about the appearance of Dark
Rey, rather than imply something plot-related.
The initial use of "vision" in the StarWars.com
article implies that Dark Rey is a premonition
of a possible dark future, a pretty common
thing in Star Wars, and the subsequent removal
of the word could be interpreted as the website
sealing off a leak.
Or it could have been an honest mistake that
led to a semantics argument.
“My Vision.
They really did take everything from me."
"You set the terms.
You can change them."
Though "vision" is just one word, there's
far too much room for interpretation when
it's used in any other way besides talking
about a Force-fueled hallucination, especially
since the hottest theory regarding Dark Rey
is that she is in fact some kind of antagonistic
apparition that appears at a pivotal moment
in the film.
Fans may be stuck on the idea that Dark Rey
is definitely a vision in The Rise of Skywalker,
appearing when Rey is questioning her alignment
with the Force or when Kylo Ren is imagining
what would happen if Rey turned to the dark
side and joined the First Order, but there
are plenty more possible explanations.
Dark Rey could be a clone, or she might be
Rey's evil twin sister who waited until the
eleventh hour to show up.
Or she could be real.
Rey could fall under the influence of Emperor
Palpatine, whom actress Daisy Ridley has said
is
"[...] very, you know, instrumental to the
plot of the film."
Will Dark Rey be revealed as a vision?
Is she the new emissary for Palpatine, or
this generation's answer to Darth Maul?
Is she a clone?
Or is this all very clever, intentional misdirection
from Lucasfilm, with the semantic slip-up
published in the StarWars.com article actually
meant to make us even more confused?
We'll only know for sure when Star Wars: The
Rise of Skywalker hits theaters December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.